I think the biggest political science
question economics question sociology
question and business opportunity if I
were looking for a start-up is basically
how we find rewarding and meaningful
work for so many people who have gotten
caught up in this hyper-connected world
and lost their jobs simply because they
have been outsourced automated digitized
cheap genius or cheap labored I think
that's the biggest not only political
science question I think that's the
biggest economic opportunity out there
today if you're looking for a startup
please don't start a social network for
people with six toes okay all right take
on something really big and that is the
big question because we are in this
world where you know they say the modern
American factory today is just a man in
a dog the man's there to feed the dog
the dog is there to keep the man away
from the machines all right that is kind
of the world we're going into that is
the world we're going into and what
that's going to mean for labor and and
job opportunities rewarding and
meaningful work so people can be in the
middle class I don't think there's any
more important question than that and so
what you had in in Jordan that was
really the question they were addressing
so I'm a group of X Silicon Valley of
jordanian former head of data for Yahoo
zombify odd went back and started a
company called Oasis 500 they invited
every young Jordanian techie that Arabic
is about 1% of language on the internet
75% of that content is produced in
Jordan but we all know that Arabic
speakers are far far more so talk about
a market that has been untapped it's
it's that market and they put out
basically an invitation to young techies
in Jordan come with your startup idea if
we like it we'll give you fifteen
thousand dollars to pursue it and you
have to enroll in a six-week boot camp
to learn how to start a company if you
graduate from boot camp will give you
office space for six months if you
survive that winnowing process we will
give
mentoring networking and investment
angel funding ourselves they're now
getting 450 applications a month they
have already launched about 60 companies
and what is so exciting as one of the
lead innovator says you know this isn't
about creating jobs it's a proud in
creating companies and companies our
growth stories they not only create jobs
but they spin off people who start more
companies and if you're going to have a
sustainable Arab Spring it cannot be
sustainable without jobs for what is the
biggest youth bulge in the world gotta
be that's why he's organization yeah
yeah changeup managed to change the
world